- [Nahre] We'd like to thank
Audible for supporting PBS.
- [LA] How we access
music is always evolving.
From vinyl records to
cassette tapes to streaming.
But a streaming service like
Spotify isn't just changing
how we access music,
it's actually changing the music itself.
Spotify has been upending
the music industry
for a solid decade.
100 million subscribers have some
35 million songs on their
fingertips for $10 a month.
This new business model
has completely changed
the way musicians make money.
As New York Times music
critic Jon Caramanica put it,
"I think it's probably easier than ever
to make a little bit of money.
I think it's harder than
ever to make a lot of money."
- But the change isn't only economic.
Bands now need to vie For a
coveted spot on one of Spotify's
curated playlist to reach
the millions of listeners
who tune into these playlists every week.
- When I saw "Capsize"
made New Music Friday,
we were up in a hotel, and I was running
around the hotel, like screaming and--
- He came and got me, yeah.
- I felt like we made it,
like we won the lottery.
- Does Spotify influence your music?
- I think we'd love to
say it doesn't (laughing)
but, at least I think,
it's in my head, probably,
and it's a weird thing to think about,
like there's this trick
of sliding choruses
up to the beginning of songs
just to catch somebody on a playlist,
'cause a lot of those listeners
are just passive listeners,
they're not your followers.
You're competing with
so much noise per week,
so you gotta do something that
grabs people right up front.
- This competition is
actually pushing some artists
to change how they write songs
in order to optimize
their music for Spotify.
That might sound like the
music world is selling out,
but is it really anything new?
Not really.
- Format has always changed
the way artists make music.
In the early 20th century,
the poor sound quality
of the phonograph influenced
some early jazz bands
to replace their double bass with a tuba,
so listeners could actually
hear the instrument.
("Black Horse Stomp")
In the 1920s, Russian
composer Igor Stravinsky
composed each of the four movements
in his "Serenade in A"
to be three minutes long,
so each could fit on one
side of the 78 RPM record.
Soon, blues and country
musicians found themselves
trimming down songs to
fit on records, too.
It's a trend that would
extend for decades,
well into the FM radio era.
Mark Katz, author of "Capturing Sound:
"How Technology has Changed Music,"
told Smithsonian Magazine,
"The three-minute pop song is basically
an invention of the phonograph."
So, Spotify is just a new phonograph.
- To understand how
Spotify is changing music,
you have to follow the money.
Spotify pays copyright holders
about $0.006 to $0.0084 per stream.
But only if the listener streams the song
for at least 30 seconds.
- If they don't stick around
for at least 30 seconds,
the artists don't get paid.
(wrong answer tone buzzes)
- This has created a few
key incentives for artists.
One is to put more songs on each album.
More songs means more
opportunities to make money,
and you can see this in recent albums
like Migos' "Culture II"
and Drake's "Scorpion,"
each of which packed a couple dozen songs.
- More songs could also
help an album go gold.
In 2016, the Recording
Industry Association of America
started factoring streams into the method
of certifying gold and platinum albums.
So with more songs per album,
artists can increase their
chances of getting more streams,
and possibly see their album go gold.
(cymbals tinkling)
- But while albums
might be getting longer,
pop songs are actually getting shorter.
In 2013, the average
song on the Billboard 100
was three minutes and 50 seconds,
according to a recent report from Quartz.
In 2018, that average dipped
to three minutes and 30 seconds.
What does it have to do with Spotify?
The answer could be related
to Spotify's 30 second rule.
Because the platform pays out
when a stream lasts 30 seconds,
there's little financial incentive
to write super long songs.
- There is, however, an incentive
to hook listeners quickly.
Gone are the days of elaborate intros.
Now, you're more likely to hear
artists frontload a song with choruses,
or go for broke in the first
few seconds of the song.
Like in Katy Perry's "Swish Swish,"
which opens with a familiar
sample from Fatboy Slim.
♪ They know what is what ♪
♪ But they don't know what is what ♪
In 2017, singer-songwriter Emily Warren
told Pitchfork that session musicians,
"Have generally been saying, 'oh, we need
"'to make something that
sounds like Spotify.'"
- So, what is the Spotify sound?
"Lean On" by Major Lazer
and DJ Snake, featuring MØ,
is a pretty good example.
With more than one billion
listeners on Spotify,
the 2015 hit was once the
platform's most streamed song.
But what made it so
optimized for streaming?
For one, the song opens with
a catchy syncopated statement
of the main chords,
before quickly getting into MØ's vocals.
♪ Do you recall ♪
♪ That long ago ♪
The rest of "Lean On" contains elements
you're likely to find in many
successful songs on Spotify.
It's got a danceable
four-on-the-floor beat.
("Lean On")
It's got a simple and catchy chorus.
♪ Blow a kiss, fire a gun ♪
♪ All we need is somebody to lean on ♪
It's under three minutes long,
and it's also clearly influenced
by streaming music's
first signature genre,
tropical house, which is a lighter take
on the deep house genre.
(tropical beat)
Trop house exploded in popularity
on Spotify around 2015,
bringing tropical sounding synthesizers
and dancehall elements
to a mainstream audience.
"Lean On" also features one of pop music's
recently favorite
conventions, the pop drop,
which is essentially a toned-down version
of an EDM bass drop.
♪ All we need is somebody to lean on ♪
- "Lean On" is an
expertly crafted pop song
that's broadly appealing and familiar.
Those are good qualities to have,
if your goal is to succeed on Spotify.
After all, studies have
shown that people prefer
music that they're familiar with,
and streaming data
indicates that people tend
not to skip songs that
they've heard before.
Many listeners today engage
in what digital marketers have dubbed,
"lean-back listening."
This term describes Spotify listeners
who prefer to select a
playlist and let it roll,
rather than selecting songs individually.
Music that is familiar and accessible
is more likely to blend
in with a playlist,
and avoid getting skipped.
Offset, of Migos, said he's
obsessed with industry data,
and uses it to modify how
he approaches writing music.
But does tailoring your art
for the aggregate preferences
of a streaming service
make songwriting any less creative?
Grammy award winner Sarah
McLachlan seems to think so.
She told the CBC, "If
people are writing music
"for that particular format,
then I find that sad."
And she would know sad.
Check out our sad song episode.
(LA singing "Angel" by Sarah McLachlan)
- But could the opposite be true?
Is it possible that Spotify's incentives
are merely tweaking what's always been
a heavily commercialized art form?
- I happen to like pop
music, he likes pop music,
so we make, probably, together
somewhat accessible music,
that has a home on some
of these platforms.
I think you have to write good songs,
but I don't think you
can think too heavily on,
this is gonna work great on Spotify.
- Is there a Spotify
sound in your opinion?
- There is the Spotify sound,
and for a while there is was mumble rap.
- I think that Spotify Song
is ever-changing, probably,
from season to season.
- LA and I are going to write a song
with all of the elements Spotify loves,
and hopefully it ends up
with a billion streams.
Well, what do you think about Spotify?
- I think it definitely has changed
how music is made, how we listen to music,
and I think we should play with,
in the song that we create,
is the length of it, length of the song.
I think it should be a 30 second song.
A 30 second song. (laughing)
- So, typical "Sound Field" fashion.
I think we should be appealing to Gen Z.
- And they're streaming natives.
- They're streaming a lot.
- We are streaming immigrants,
like we grew up with other things.
- We'll do it.
- [LA] Let's get it.
Before we hear our Spotify-style track,
we'd like to thank Audible
for supporting PBS.
Audible's selection of audiobooks
includes Audible originals, audio titles
created by storytellers from
around the literary world.
For example, "Pitch," an
Audible original series
that illustrates why music is so central
in our connections to each other,
our history, and culture.
Visit Audible.com/SoundField,
or text SOUNDFIELD to
500 500 to learn more.
Members own their books and
can access them anytime.
To learn more, visit
Audible.com/SoundField,
or text SOUNDFIELD to 500 500.
("Spotify Song")
- Gen Z is streaming natives,
but they're immigrants to opening a CD
and peeling the sticker off,
and looking at the liner notes
and seeing the poster in there.
They don't know anything about that.
But I think, what were
you talking about, genre?
What were you talking about?
(inspirational music sting)